I would argue that we should do social
media first I think they should make
money on like female influencers somehow
like manage their social media accounts
but then the problem is those
influencers are just going to start
getting naked I I think you could do
like reality TV around women's sports
like I think the only way you're really
going to make money is through
entertainment or selling sex I love
women's sports but honestly the more
they whine and about pay I just
say take it away I say I would cut the
whole league if I was men because all
they do is whine and I I think women as
athletes we should be grateful that the
men allow us to have these leagues